[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
قصف روسي اوكرانيا
بينها تركيب وسبريجيا
مسؤول اوروبي يكشف صعوبه التقدم في
المفاوضات النوويه مع ايران للخرافها في
حرب اوكرانيه
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول ان الاحتجاجات في
ايران تجاوزت الحدود القوميه والجغرافيه
زعيم حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي في تونس
امام محكمه تونسيه اليوم بتهمي تلقي
تموينات اجنبيه
اهلا بكم الى هذه النشره البدايه من حرب
اوكرانيا حيث ارتفعت وتيره القصف المتبادل
العنيف بين القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه في
دنيتك وافاد مراسل العربيه بان اوكرانيا
اعلنت حاله الانذار الجوي في خمس مقاطعات
من بينها تركيز وزابريجيا هذا وتواصل
القوات الروسيه عملياتها الهجوميه بالقرب
بخموت ديفكه كما تعزي التجمعاتها في غرب
دنيتك وتشون هجمات مضاده محدوده على طول
الخط كريمي كريمينيا وفي الوقت نفسه وصلت
القوات الاوكرانيه استهداف الخدمات
اللوجستيه العسكريه الروسيه في دنيه
في اوكرانيا ايضا ارتفعت حصيله القصف
الاوكراني على معسكر للمجندين الروسي
مكيفكا الى 89 قتيلا فيما توعدت روسيا
بالرد على عمليه القصف
غضب في مدن روسيه ودعواتنا لمعقبه القاده
العسكريين المسؤولين عن مقتل المجندين في
مكه الورود التي حملتها اهالي ضحايا
ووضعتها على ضريح الجندي المجهول تحميل
بقدر الحزن السيايا ومطالبه باجابات عن
موته كان من الممكن تفاديه وخصوصا ان
الاهالي يتهمون القيادات العسكريه
بالتقصير وعدم توفير الحمايه اللازمه
للمجندين خصوصا بعد قرار السماحي باستخدام
الهواتف في ما سهاما في تحديد القوات
الاوكرانيه لموقعهما مقابله مطالب الاهالي
يبرز وعيد سياسي وبرلماني يطالب بمعقبه
القاده العسكريين بتهمه تجاهل المخاطر
مدون عسكري روسي يتابعه اكثر من 700,000
شخص على تيليجرام وصف لاستهدافه بالمروعه
والقاب اللوم على قاده الجيش الروسي
من الذي اتى بفكره وضع مجندين باعداد
كبيره في مبنى واحد فاي استهداف سيخلف
الكثير من القتل والجرحى يقول خبراء
عسكريون روز ان الهجوم الاوكراني الذي نفذ
في صواريخهم اسكباروسيا خساره هي الافدح
عسكريا ومعنويا خصوصا من ناحيه تاثير على
اقبال الشبان الروس على تجنيد اضافه الى
تعثر الحمله العسكريه التي اقتربت من
انهاء عامها الاول بدون اي انجازات تذكر
اعلن حاكم بول عاصمه شبه جزيره القرم
اسقاط طائرتين مسيرتين اطلقتهما اوكرانيا
باتجاه مطار بلبيك العسكري الروسي وكانت
تقارير اوكرانيه اكدت سماع دوي انفجارات
مرتين على الاقل بالقرب من هذا الميناء
الذي يطل على البحر الاسود
كيف هي الانتقادات داخل روسيا حول هذا
الحدث
مرحبا فاطمه نعم صحيح ما تقولون صحيح ما
تقولين الاعداد ترتفع الى تسعه و 80 شخصا
حسب الروايه الرسميه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه لكن حتى هذه اللحظه طبعا الاصابات
والجرحى بالعشرات ومن المتوقع ان يرتفع
هذا العدد خلال الساعات القادمه طبعا
انتقادات كبيره من الداخل الروسي ان كان
طبعا من الجنوب او من داخل موسكو لسير
العمليه العسكريه خاصه ما حدث العيد راس
السنه في ثانيه وسقوط عشرات القتلى طبعا
كان همم من المتوقع كما يرى الكثير من
المدونين العسكريين في البلاد كما يرى
العديد من رجال السياسه يعني الخروج من
هذه الازمه وعدم الوصول الى ما حدث طبعا
ان كان تم بالاخذ بعين الاعتبار جميع
الخطط لسلامه الجنود الذين هم من الاصل تم
تعبئاتهم في الاونه الاخيره خاصه مع هذه
الازمه بنقص الجنود في الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وعلى خط المواجهه الاول طبعا هذه
الانتقادات تحدث الكثير من رجال السياسه
والعسكر عنها يوم امس وطبعا بيان وزاره
الدفاع الاخير تحدث لسراما بان دفاع موسكو
ستقوم بمحاسبه المسؤولين عند الانتهاء من
التحقيق بقضيه ماساه دانيتك وسقوط عشرات
القتلى والجرح بهذه القضيه
عبد الجواد الكثير يتحدث
عن الاجراءات التي يتخذها المسؤولين او
المسؤولون الروس هل تسمعني عبد الجواد
نعم اسالك عن الاجراءات التي سيتخذها
المسؤولون لتفادي حدوث هذه الحادثه مجددا
في المستقبل
سريه الكثير من التقارير تتحدث عن ان
الهواتف المحموله يعني هي السبب الرئيس في
الوصول الى النقاط لكن الخبراء التقنيين
بهذا الموضوع يتحدثون بانه لا يمكن
اماكن تواجد الجنود في نقطه محدده وانما
الموضوع يحتاج لصور من الاقمار الصناعيه
باعتبار ان مراكز الارسال الموجوده في تلك
المنطقه يمكنها تحديد عدد المكالمات بشكل
كبير لكنها لا يمكن لا يمكنها اعطاء
احداثيات وجود الهواتف النقاله طبعا الخطط
والاعلان الموجوده طبعا عملت عليه موسكو
سابقا عندما تواجدنا في الدوباس عندما
تواجدنا في مناطق عديده طبعا كان يتم سحب
الهواتف النقاله كان يتم العنايه بامور
سوريا لكن على ما يبدو هناك تقصير كبير
والجانب الروسي اصبح يتحدث عن هذا الشيء
على ذلك وطبعا
السياسيون بصراحه
الروسيه عندما تقول انهم لا يمكنهم تحديد
احداثيات اماكن الجوالات هل هذا يعني ان
هناك اختراق
يعني الموضوع قد يكون مرتبط بصور من
الاقمار الصناعيه قد يكون مرتبط باشخاص
استخبرتين يعملون لصالح الجانب الاوكراني
كانوا قد سلموا احداثيات المنطقه وقد تكون
طبعا كيف حصلت على تقنيات جديده يمكن من
خلالها تحديد مواقع تواجد الجنود لكن طبعا
مهما كانت الاسباب فاطمه الجميع في موسكو
من سياسيين وعسكريين يجتمعون على انه من
الخطا الكبير جمع هذا العدد كالكبير في
مركز لتوزيع الجنود الذين تم تعبئهنم في
الاونه الاخيره بالقرب من مخزن لي السلاح
ولل الذكيره وهذا طبعا يعتبر خطا في سير
المعارك العسكريه كما يتحدث شكرا
معنى من كيف الصحفي محمد البابا اهلا بك
معنا سيد محمد اذا ااه انذار جوي في خمسه
ما مناطق في اوكرانيا ما شان ذلك هناك هل
لك ان تنقل لنا الصوره
الاولى بسبب اطلاق روسيا للمسيرات وقصف
على منطقه
وايضا هناك معلومات عن سقوط ضحيه وجرح سته
اخرين ايضا يعني وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اعلنت انها تتعدد من السيارات التي اطلقت
من روسيا من رستم ومن شبه الجزيره
وفوقها مقاطعه همم نيكا لايف مدينه ايضا
تعرضت للسقوط صاروخ 300 ولكن حتى يعني عند
الساعه الثامنه انتهى الانذار الجوي وعدد
الامور الى طبيعتها ولكن يعني الجديد
اليوم في العاصمه الالكترونيه كيف بعوده
التقنين وبشكل جزء الى التقنيه في التيار
الكهربائي وذلك همم فتح مجال لاصلاح
الاعطال التي او المكان الذي تم استهدافه
في الضربات الاخيره التي طالت العاصمه
الالكترونيه ليله راس السنه وفي يوم واحد
كل 31 من الشهر الماضي ولكن يعني الان
العمليات العسكريه التجري بشكل كبير في
قطاع الجمباز او وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
اعلنت صباح هذا اليوم انها سيطرت بشكل
كامل على طريق رقم 66 وهذا الطريق الرئيسي
يمتد من سباتهوفا باتجاه كلمينيا وروبيجنا
والى لسه ويعطي وكان يعتبر هذا الطريق
الطريق الرئيسي لامداد القوات الروسيه
بالاسلحه والذخائر والمواد اللوجستيه
للقوات التي تقاتل في قطاع همم مدينه
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا اكد ان هناك تطور
كبير لتحرك قواته التي تستطيع وبسب يعني
عمل الاستخبارات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
تستطيع الحصول على معلومات عن اهداف
والطرق التي يتعامل بها الجيش الروسي
ومواعيد واماكن التي يقوم بها الجيش
الروسي الهجوم على المراكز الاوكرانيه
لذلك الجيش اوكراني منذ ثلاثه اشهر حتى
اليوم اصبح لديه اليد العليا في شرق
اوكرانيا
سؤالي هنا التقدم في بعض الاحيان انواع
لديه المعدات
الكافيه
لتحديد احداثيات وهمم معلومات الجيش
الروسي
لديه شبكه استخبارات والاستخبارات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الجور كما تسمى لتقوم
بعمل رهيب وكبير جدا وعملها يقدر في
اوكرانيا
يعني هذه الجهه في الجيش الاوكراني وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه هي التي تقوم ببعض
العمليات وارسال مسيرات الى العمق الروسي
وتحديد يعني اماكن تواجد الطائرات التي
تقوم بالقصف على اوكرانيا مثلا يعني كان
يتداول في وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان
المطار الذي تم قصفه همم في انجلت هذا
المطار كانت تقلع منها طائرات التي تقوم
باطلاق الصواريخ على الاراضي الاوكرانيه
واستطاعت القوات الاوكرانيه تدمير ثلاثه
تعتبر طائرات استراتيجيه ايضا العم التي
حصلت في او الهجوم الصاروخ الذي حصل على
قاعده عسكريه في منطقه هذا انجاز
للمخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه التي
استطاعت تحديد مخزن من الصواريخ ومدافع
وايضا لصواريخ اجراءات التي تنقل المناطق
الحدوديه بين اوكرانيا او مناطق الخطوط
التماس بين اوكرانيا والانفصاليين استطاع
الجيش الاوكراني تدمير هذا المخزن الذي
يعتبر مخزن له الذخيره في قطاع الجمباز
وايضا بالقضاء على كما يتداول فيه الاوساط
الاعلاميه الاوكرانيه اكثر من 400 جندي
روسي قتلوا بسبب هذه ولذلك الان في روضه
في قطاع الجمباز وايضا الجيش الاوكراني
اصبح يعني كقابه كوثر
وفي حال الجيش الالكتروني هو عنده ما
يستطيع الجيش الدخول الى تلك المدن
شكرا تقريبا
اساسيه اصبحت بيد الجيش الاكرانيا شكرا لك
من كيف الصحفي محمد البابا
ما جاعتهن عالميه مشاهدينا تقترب اكثر كل
ما بعدت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في افقت
داعيتها واثارها ما العلاقه بينهما وكيف
تاثر العالم اجمع بتلك التداعيات لنشاهد
[موسيقى]
نجرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل تركيه
تطمئن المعارضه السوريه وتتمسك بالتطبيع
مع نظام الاسد و واشنطن تحذر
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد
الاحتجاجات في ايران بالعفويه واعتبر
برايسي مؤتمر صحفي ان الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
الايرانيه تجاوزت حدود القوميه والجغرافيه
ولا تقودها ايرادات محدده لذلك استمرت
بخلاف الاحتجاجات السابقه وفقه قوله واوضح
برايس ايضا ان تركيزه واشنطن لم يعد على
احياء الاتفاق النووي خاصه منذ شهر سبتمبر
السيناتور الجمهوري تدروس اشار الى ان
القضاء على القائد السابق لفريق القدس في
الحرس الثوري الايراني قاسم سليمان قوض
بشكل كبير قدره النظام الايراني على شانه
الارهاب على مستوى العالم
الجمهوري اكد ايضا ان سليماني كان متورطا
في مؤامرات مستمره لمهاجمه امريكا
وحلفائها في جميع انحاء العالم مضيفا ان
على العالم ان يدرك ان النظام الايراني
ووكلائه في المنطقه لا يزال يشكل تهديدا
كبيرا مؤكدا ان بلاده ستستمر في مواجهه
تحديد الارهابي الايراني
[موسيقى]
الالماني بتصنيف الحرس الثوري الايراني
منظمه ارهابيه كما قدم مجموعه نشطاء
سياسيين في المانيا طلبات للبرلمان
ضد الحارس الثوري وتاتي المطالبات
الالمانيه بعد تقارير بريطانيه مماثله
اشارت الى عزم البرلمان البريطاني تصنيف
الحرس الثوري كمنظم ارهابيه واكدت المصادر
ان الاعلان سيتم في غضون اسابيع وبيدعم من
وزير الامن البريطاني ووزيره الداخليه
كذلك بدورها اشارت ريناتا من الحزب
الديمقراطي الحر في البرلمان الالماني في
تغريده الى عزمي المانيا ادراج الحرس
الثوري على قائمه الجماعات الارهابيه
مضيفه انه يجب على المانيا ان تدافع عن
حقوق الانسان بشكل اكثر صراحه وبسرعه ويجب
ان يتم ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني في
قائمه الجماعات الارهابيه فورا
اشارت ايضا نائبه المانيه في البرلمان
الاوروبي هناء نيومن الى استمرار يقمع
الاحتجاجات بيد النظام الايراني واحتمال
اعدام المتظاهرين واوضحت انه وفي ظل
الاحتجاجات المستمره سيزداد الوضع سوءا
اذا التزم المجتمع الدولي الصمت تجاه ما
يحدث في ايران وايضا نستمر في ايران حيث
احرق محتجون في مناطق متفرقه صورا لقاسم
سليماني في ذكرى مقتله
في السياقي ذاته كشفت مصادر سياسيه عراقيه
عن ان الذكرى السنويه الثالثه لاغتيال
قاسم سليماني تحولت الى مناسبه انقسام حاد
بين حساب الاطار التنسيقي نتيجه ما
يتداوله هنشطاء مقربون من الفصائل الشيعيه
وطهران عن ان حكومه محمد شائعه السوداني
وافقت على طلب امريكي بمنع مسيره مليونيه
لسليماني في العراق وفق الشرق الاوسط
واوضح المصدر سياسي مشاهدينا ان قاده في
الاطار التنسيقي تخوفوا من تكرار مشاهد
الحشود الغاضبه في محيط السفاره الامريكيه
لو سمح للانصار باقامه انشطه تابين
سليماني من دون قيود
معنى من برلين مراسله العربيه راغده بهنام
اهلا بك معنا راغده اذن المطالبات
للبرلمان الالماني لتصنيف الحرس الثوري
منظمه ارهابيه كيف يجري ذلك
اهلا بك هناك مجموعه من النواب في الواقع
داخل البرلمان الالماني ينتمون للحزب
الاشتراك الحاكم الذي ينتمي اليها
المستشارلز هم يقومون برعايه سجناء داخل
ايران اي مساعداتهم في الاجراءات
القانونيه ولتحدي المحاكمات الصوريه كما
قال لنا احد هؤلاء النواب الاسبوع الماضي
هؤلاء وقعوا على عريضه او على وثيقه تدعوا
الحكومه للتشدد اكثر مع ايران ولتصنيف
الحارس الثوري الايراني ضمن المنظمات
الارهابيه الان يعرف هؤلاء لانه
هكذا خطوه كما اكدت الحكومه الالمانيه
مرارا يجب ان تصدر عن داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي تكون خطوه منسقه بين كامل دول
الاتحاد لكي يكون لها مفعول همم اقوى ولكن
يقولون بانه بهذه الوثيقه يريدون تمكين
وزيره الخارجيه من موقف اقوى داخل الاتحاد
الاوروبي لكي تتمكن من اقناع الدول الاخرى
التي ربما يعني متردده او لديها عوائق
نونيه داخل دوليها بدعم هكذا خطوه
الخارجيه هنا ان كان هناك
اوروبيه جديه ل- اا تصنيف الحرس الثوري
منظمه ارهابيه
بالفعل هناك نقاشات داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
يترجم منذ اسابيع لتصنيف الحارس الثوري
منظمه ارهابيه كان هناك اجتماع عقد قبل
الفرصه الاعياد ناقشت هذه المساله ولكن
يعني لم يكن هناك اتفاق او توافق داخل كل
الدول لتصنيف المنظمه يعني بشكل كامل
ونظام ارهابيه وصدر حينها فقط عقوبات على
اشخاص داخل الحارس السوري الايراني ووضعوا
على اللائحه السوداء ولكن هذه الجهود لم
تتوقف رغم انه المحاوله الاولى لم تكن
ناجحه المفاوضات داخل الدول هذه المجموعه
مستمره او المشورات مستمره له يعني همم
تخطي على العقبه داخل بعض الدول التي تمنح
حتى الان تصنيف الحدث السوري منظمه
ارهابيه المانيا مستمر الى جانبه هولندا
في الواقع بيتدفع همم الدول الاوروبيه
التي اخذها كذا خطوه هناك يعني توافق ايضا
همم ربما يمكن القول همم الماني فرنسي
بريطاني هذه الدول الثلاثه التي كانت
مشاركه في المفاوضات النوويه بانه الان
الاولويه هي لي همم معاقبه النظام على
قمعه للاحتجاجات وليس الدفع باتجاه حل
سياسه للعوده للاتفاق النووي لذلك هذه
الجود الكلوماسيه من المتوقع ان تشهد دفعا
جديدا في الايام المقبله يعني بعد انتهاء
فرصه الاعياد همم وقد تشهد يعني اوروبا او
الاتحاد الاوروبي تحركا شبريها بالذي
ستتخذه لندن في الاسابيع المقبله لجهه
السوري منظمه ارهابيه شكرا لك من برلين
مراسله العربيه
شدد مسؤول اوروبي على صعوبه احداث خرق في
المفاوضات النوويه مع ايران بسبب انخراطها
في الحرب في اوكرانيا وقال المسؤول
الاوروبي لموقع جاد ايران ان طهيران وضعت
نفسها في ازمه كبيره وذلك بسبب الوضع
الداخلي وقمع الاحتجاجات ونقل الاسلحه الى
روسيا رغم التحذيرات من عواقب ذلك واضاف
المسؤول الاوروبي ان الايرانيين يعرفون
انهم يزدادون عزله وان القرار بيدخمني
وليس وزاره الخارجيه او الرئيس ابراهيم
رئيسه
الولايات المتحده ابداعات الثلاثاء دول
العالم قاطبه الى عدم تطبيع علاقاتها مع
نظام بشار الاسد الذي وصفته بالديكتاتور
الوحشي وذلك في معرض تعليقها على اللقاء
الذي جمع اخيرا في موسكو وزيراي الدفاع
السوري والتركي وقال المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه
للصحفيين نحن لا ندعم الدول التي تعزز
علاقاتها او تعرب عن دعمها لاعاده
الاعتبار لبشر الاسد الديكتاتور الوحشي
وحد برايس الدول على ان تدرس بعنايه ما
وصفه بسجل حقوق الانسان المروع للنظام
الاسد على مدى السنوات الماضيه والاربعاء
الماضي عقد في موسكو اجتماع ضمه وزراء
الدفاع الروسي التركي والسوري تناول تقارب
مع نظام بشار الاسد وزير الخارجيه مولود
شاويش اوغلو عقد اجتماعا مع قاده المعارضه
السوريه لتهدئه مخاوفهم عاقبا لله تظاهرات
في شمال سوريا تمدد بالتقارب التركي مع
نظام السوري ونشر وزير الخارجيه التركيه
على تويتر صورتين من لقائه رئيس الائتلاف
الوطني لقوه الثوره السوريه سالم المصلط
وقاده اخرين في انقره قائلا ان موقف انقر
صيدله داعما للمعارضه السوريه والشعب
السوري وفقا لقرار مجلس الامن الدولي رقم
2 2 5 4
وافاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان وقوع
انفجارات في محيط حقل العمر النفطي الذي
تتخذه قوه التحالف الدولي قاعده عسكريه في
ريف دير الزور الشرقي واضاف المرصد ان هذه
الانفجارات تحديدا تزامنت مع تحليق طائرات
مسيره في اجواء المنطقه المرصد اشار ايضا
الى ان تضارب المعلومات حول ما اذا كانت
الانفجارات ناجمه عن تدريبات عسكريه مكثفه
للتحالف قصف من الفصائل المواليه لايران
انتقاما لمقتل قائد فيلق القدس في الحرس
الثوري الايراني
في تونس تنظر الدائره للجناحيه بالمحكمه
الابتدائيه في ما يعرف بقضيه اللوبيين
والمتعلقه بتلقي حركه النهضه تمويلات
اجنبيه في انتخابات 2019
المتهم فيها رئيس الحركه راشد الغنوشي
وصهره رفيق بشلاكه ياتي ذلك عقب ان قررت
هيئه الدائره تاخير النظر في القضيه الى
الشهر الحالي علما ان الغنوشي تغيب عن
جلسه المحكمه
نشره هنا مستمره مشاهدينا ونتابع فيها
كريستيانو رونالدو يعد يعيد النصر السعودي
بتحطيم الارقام القياسيه
احييكم من جديد طلبت دوله الامارات والصين
عقد اجتماعا علنيا لمجلس الامن لمناقشه
التطورات الاخيره في المسجد الاقصى حسب
دبلوماسيين قبل ذلك قال مسؤول في مكتب
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
انه ملتزمون بالحفاظ على الوضع القائم في
المسجد الاقصى وذلك بعد اقتحام وزير الامن
القومي باحات الاقصى
حراسه مشدده
[موسيقى]
هذا بايظه مكتوب
الممثل الخاص لوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
لشؤون الشرق الاوسط
قال انا ايام محاولات للتاثير على علاقه
موسكو بدول الشرق الاوسط وابعادها عن حل
لازماتهم مثل الازمه الفلسطينيه
الاسرائيليه هي محاولات محكوم عليها
بالفشل وهو هراء على حد قوله سوفرين كوب
اشار ايضا الى ان واشنطن تعزل نفسها في
عمل اللجنه الرباعيه للتسويه في الشرق
الاوسط وتحاول ايضا خاص خاصه الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي بالكامل الامر الذي
يشكل مهمه مستحيله بحسب وصف الممثل الخاص
لوزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
في تونس تنظر الدائره الجناحيه بالمحكمه
الابتدائيه في ما يعرف بقضيه اللوبيين
والمتعلقه بتلقي حركه النهضه تمويلات
اجنبيه في انتخابات 2019 المتهم فيها رئيس
الحركه راشد الغنوشي وصهره رفيق بشلاكه
عقب ان قررت هيئه الدائره تاخير النظر في
القضيه الى الشهر الحالي علما ان الغنوشي
تغيب عن جلسه المحكمه
مرحبا تحالفات سياسيه في السودان
بالمبادره المصريه التي تستهدف جمع
الاطراف السودانيه على طاوله واحده وذلك
لحل خلافتهم في وقت تحفظت كتله المجلس
المركزي على دخولك ياناس سياسيه في
الاتفاق الايطالي وبحسب مصادر مشاهدينا
فان بعض القوى السياسيه بالفعل دخلت في
اجتماعات للبحث فرص نجاح المبادره المصريه
في الخرطوم
مبادره تاتي بعد غياب المصريه عن جهود
التسويه السياسيه في السودان لكن يعتمد
نجاحها على مدى تقبل القوى السياسيه
السودانيه للدوري المصري طبعا في قوه
مقاومه هتكون من القوى السياسيه
لكن انا اظن في تقدير الشخصي انه في ضروره
موضوعيه للتوافق السوداني وان السوداني
ذلك في ادوار للدوله معطله في وظائف معطله
في تهديدات امنيه متصاعده في مشاكل
اقتصاديه متصاعده بلد محتاجه حكومه محتاجه
سلطه تنفيذيه محتاجه سلطه امنيه متوافق
عليها لا تمارس عنفا في الشارع وتمارس
دورا في الحمايه
للوصول الى حاله من التوافق بين القوى
السياسيه سودانيه تقابله حاجه ماسه للحفاظ
على مقومات الدوله السودانيه وهو ما يدركه
الجميع ولكن هل تتوفر لديهم هذه الاراده
لنا يعقوب تقف جنوب مجرى هذا النهر وربما
يكون لديها اجابه
تامر فعوضه مصر الى واجهه السياسيه في
السودان تاتي هذه المره عبر مبادره يحملها
مدير المخابرات المصري لحل الازمه بين
الاطراف السودانيه تقول مصادر العربيه ان
المبادره تستهدف ثلاث كتل الرئيسيه وجمعهم
في لقاء لخلافاتهم على ان يكون هذا الحل
سودانيا خالصا
مدير المخابرات المصريه عباس كامل تلقى
ضوء اخضر من رئيس مجلس السياده لقياده
المبادره ليشرع بعد ساعتين في لقاء الكتله
الديمقراطيه والقوه الوطنيه والمجلس
المركزي ورغم ترحيبه جميع الاطراف الا ان
الاخيره جدد طلبه المعلن لعباس كامل بان
يتم اشراقه قوه معينه وليس جميع الاحزاب
السياسيه
ان تدخل الحركات المسلحه خاصه حركه مناوي
وحركه العدل والمساواه الى هذا الاتفاق
بجانب ادخال الحزب الاتحاد
بتكون همم اضافه رقم كبير جدا الاتفاق على
الايطالي
ساعات قليله واجتماعات محدوده لمدير
المخابرات المصريه مع الاحزاب السياسيه في
الخرطوم والتي دخل بعضها اليوم في
اجتماعات لبحث فرص نجاح الرؤيه المصريه
وتسريع ايقاع المشهد المتباطئ في السودان
ليطل سؤال بلا جواب واضح كيف سينسق
القائمون على المبادره الجديده مع الوسطاء
الذين اوصلوا الاطراف الى اتفاق الاطاري
ارجاء مجلس النواب الامريكي الى مساء
اليوم جلسه انتخاب رئيس الا هو ذلك بعد
ثلاث جولات اقتراع فشلت خلالها الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه في حشد الاصوات اللازمه
للانتخاب مرشحها كيفن مكارسي رئيسا للمجلس
في سابقه 100 عام مشاهدينا وخلال جولات
الاقتراع الثلاث المتتاليه فشله النائب عن
ولايه كاليفورنيا في اقناع مجموعه من
زملائه من مؤيد الرئيس السابق
بانتخابه خلفا لنانسي فلوسي
اكثر مما ينبغي وتعكس هذه النتيجه
الخلافات في صفوف الجمهوريين الذين فازوا
بالاغلبيه في مجلس النواب بعد انتخابات
منتصف الولايه من بيروت معنا استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور سامي نادر اهلا
بك معنا دكتور ما شان هذه الانقسامات بين
الحزب الجمهوري ان لم يتفقوا ويخرجوا
برئيس لهم ما الاجراءات المتخذه
يعني اليوم كل النظام السياسي الامريكي
معطل لانه اذا لم يتم انتخاب رئيس مجلس
النواب لا يمكن انتخاب كافه الاعضاء
ورئاسه ورؤساء اللجان وبالتالي كل العمل
التشريعي والعمل المؤسسات في الولايات
المتحده
معطل ويبدو حتى الساعه ان التصويت لرئيس
شديد قد يطول فليس هنالك نيه بعد
انسحابتي
وحظوظ ماكرتي بالفوز على الاقل حسب اربعه
ما زالت قائمه حتى لو لم اا حتى لو هي
ضعيفه
وبالتالي نحن امام مسار قد يطول يعني
ذكرتم في التقرير ان هناك سابقا منذ 100
سنه هذا همم صحيح وفي الوقت همم يعني تطلب
الامر شهرين و103 130 همم 33 دورا
انتخابيه لكي يصار الى انتخاب رئيس
مجلس النواب همم وهذا يدل على اصلا
الانقسام السياسي الحاد ليس فقط بين
الديمقراطيين وجمهوريين ولكن داخل الحزب
الجمهوري هذه السمه همم الاساسيه همم
ظاهره بدات عام 2010
وتكرست وتعمقات مع اصول دونالد ترامب وكل
الداعمين زيدون اقامه
الجمهوري طيب ما ان لم يتمكنوا من الوصول
على اتفاق على ميكورسي اليس هناك مرشح اخر
ربما
كان هنالك مرشحين تقدم جوردان حصل على 19
صوت
ولكن
هذا بعد
وهذا ليس كافي اليوم
مقاله بحاجه الى 218 صوت لكي يفوز حصل على
203 اصوات لم ينسحب
بعد المعركه يسار الى التوصل الى تصفيه
ولكن السؤال اليوم من التسويات هل التسويه
مع الجناح الرديكالي الداعمين لترامب او
ما الديمقراطيين هذا هو السؤال الانتقاد
الاساسي الذي
يقوله
الداعمين مكارتي
على
الانتقادهم ل لاعبين ترامب انهم
يلعبون همم في همم
يسهلون العمليه للحزب الديمقراطي
وبالتالي همم يعني هذا سبب الانسداد
سياسي الحاصل بالتالي ما الخيارات
المطروحه امام الحزب دكتور
ليس بعد محصوم ان كان سوف يقبل بها مثلا
عمليا اقصائه عن الرئاسه وتغيير النظام
الداخلي في مجلس النواب هذا شيء مطروح
ربما همم خلف الاضواء يحاولون همم اكتساب
او الوصول الى تنازلات اخرى قد تسهل
الاجنده السياسيه لدونالد ترامب خاصه
واننا على مسافه سنتين من عند الانتخاب
هذه هي التسويات اما التسويه الاخرى
المستمعه ده هي تسويه مع الحزب الديمقراطي
ايضا على قاعده
تنازلات همم سياسيات كما كما يحصل في
التسعينات مع نيوتن جريتش حينما يعني توصل
الى تافههما معينه على بعض النقاط مع
الحسبه الديمقراطي شكرا لك من بيروت استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه الدكتور سامي نادر
مباشره الى اخبار الاقتصاد مع الزميله
فاطمه
على البورصه المصريه التي تسجل تراجعات
حاده صباح هذا اليوم لاحظوا الخسائر على
كل المكونات
سلبي مباشر مباشره بعد اصدار مصريين بنك
مصر وبنك الاهلي اصدرته شهادات ايداع
بنسبه فائده 25% التفسير الوحيد لهذه
التراجعات انه تخارج من تداولات الاسهم
والاكتتاب في شهادات الاذاعه التي تم
اصدارها من قبل البنوك المصريه كما ذكرنا
بنكي
يعني لاحظوا تراجعات على كل الاسهم
المصرفيه بدون استثناء ابو ظبي الاسلامي
القلعه القابضه خسائر بخمسه في المئه
تراجعات لبنك فيصل الاسلامي ب 16 بنك
التمويل او تعمير والاسكان متراج ايضا
بشكل كبير وتخارج على كل مكونات السوق
لربما الان العوائد هتاتي منها الشهادات
اكثر بكثير من العوائد اللي يمكن تيجي من
الاستثمار في الاسهم المصريه سوديك طلعت
مصطفى اعمار خسائر باربعه في المئه
المصريه للاتصالات ايضا نتحدث عن تراجعات
بحدود
الاربعه في اوراسكوم كونتراكشن ايضا خاسر
حوالي اثنين في المئه باقي الاسواق نتحدث
عن صوره متباينه سوق الاسهم السعوديه يضيف
0.2% موسى ماسك عند اعلى مستوى منذ شهر
تقريبا اسواق الاماراتيه
نراها تتجه الى الارتفاعات واسهم نراقبها
اللي سجلت ارتفاعات على خلفيه توزيعات
النقديه بثلاثه ريالات عن النصف الاول من
سنتها الماليه على كل ان هذا كل ما لديه
الان نحن نعود بالاسواق العربيه نحاول ان
نفسر حركه التراجعات الحاده على البورصه
المصريه اليوم عوده الى استديوهات العربيه
بالرياض وفاطمه
شكرا لك فاطمه اصبحت الصين اكثر قربا من
اعاده الانفتاح الكامل على العالم بعد
ثلاث سنوات من الاجراءات الاحترازيه والتي
فرضتها الحكومه لمواجهه فيروس كوبات 19
ومن المتوقع ان تضخ الخطوه حيويه في ثاني
اكبر اقتصاد بالعالم خلال السنه الجديده
على العالم
الى عدم وجود اي قيود تقريبا الخوف من
الاغلاق والحجر الصحي تلاشى فجاه بعد فتره
من الاضطراب ومن المرجح ان ينتعش النشاط
الاقتصادي بشكل كبير بعد الخطوه الارقام
تقول ان الناتج المحليه
2022 اي اقل بكثير من الهدف الرسمي
وهو عجز بنحو نصف تريليون دولار ما عرق
لحركه سلاسل التوريد وانخفضت الارباح التي
حققتها الشركات الصناعيه بنسبه 9% على
اساس السنوي خطوه بكين من المتوقع ان تطفي
يا حيويه على ثاني اكبر اقتصاد بالعالم في
العام الجديد وبينما يواجه الاقتصاد
العالمي تحديات كبيره بما في ذلك نقص
الطاقه النمو وارتفاعه التضخم يمكن ان
توفر اعاده الانفتاح في الصين دفعت
المطلوبه وفي الوقت المناسب
كما عشنا وكما نعلم فيروسكو في ال 19 تسبب
بعشره في المئه من المجمل الحالات الوفيات
عام 2020
و13% عام 2001 2021 في الولايات المتحده
وساهم الفيروس الى جانب تناول جرعه
المخدرات الزائده بنخفاض متوسط العمر
المتوقع الى ادنى مستوياته منذ 25 عاما
وذلك وفق بيانات المراكز الامريكيه
للسيطره على الامراض والوقايه منها
عاملان الديان الى انخفاض متوسط العمر
المتوقع في الولايات المتحده العام الماضي
الى ادنى مستوياته منذ عام
1996 الاول ظهور فيروس كورونا والثاني
تناوله جرعه زائده من المواد المخدره
مراكز السيطره على الامراض والوقايه منها
اوضحت ان هذا التراجع بدا بشكل متواصل عام
2020 حين ظهر فيروس كورونا ما يطرح
تساؤلات حول تداعيات ظهور متحورات جديده
منه خاصه في ظل موجه الثلوج والصقيع
الحليليه
اكيد يا وقت اللي صار هل طلع الكوفين اثر
على الناس اثر على البوم اثر على السكري
تبعهم الناس تاثر منه فهذا اثر الاعمار ال
ال لايف باند تبع الناس هنا في امريكا
الدنيا كلها وهذه هذه كانت نتائج
وما قد يفاقم الوضع بالنسبه لفايروس
كورونا في الولايات المتحده وفق خبراء
التسييس المستمر لمواجهه الفيروس بين
الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين بشان تلقي
اللقاحات والجرعات المعززه واجراءات
الوقايه ما اثر سلبا على قرارات
الامريكيين وزاد نسبه وفيات المصابين
الامور هذه كارثه كبيره انا بعتها السياسه
ما لازم تتدخل في الطب اطلاقا اولا وثانيا
لازم وزاره الصحه وعندك كمان السي دي سي
لازم تكون موجود بطريقه ملموسه اكثر اما
بالنسبه للوفياتي بالجرعه الزائده فقط
زادت عام 2021 بنسبه 16% تقريبا مقارنه
بعام 2020 وفقه مراكز السيطره على الامراض
البيانات الجديده تظهر ان معدله عمر
الاطفال المولودين عام 2020 في الولايات
المتحده 76 عاما واربعه اشهر بينما كان
المعدل مولودين عام 2019
78 عاما وثمانيه اشهر حسين الطود العربيه
واشنطن
في اليابان قال رئيس الوزراء فيميوكاشيدا
ان بلاده ستشدد اجراءات دخول الوافدين من
الصين اعتبارا من الاحد المقبل للحد من
انتشار كورونا واوضح ان الاجراءات
الاضافيه ستشمل الزام المسافرين على
الرحلات المباشره من الصين بتقديم نتيجه
سلبيه لفحص الفيروس ومع ذلك قبل الصعود
على متن الطائره واضافك الشتاء ان اليابان
ستستمر في مطالبه شركات الطيران بالحد من
الرحلات الاضافيه القادمه من الصين
والمتحدث باسم البيت الابيض كامل
كوريا الجنوبيه دوله غير حائزه للاسلحه
النوويه مشددهن على ما ذكره الرئيس
الامريكي المسبقا
نسوان كبيره زينه
والى جبال اللوز في السعوديه حيث شهدت
القمه في منطقه نيوم شمال غرب السعوديه
تساقط الثلوج منذ ليله الامس في درجه
حراره وصلت الى 3 درجات مئويه
[موسيقى]
ومن جبل اللوز ينضم الينا نصفيان مراسل
العربيه اهلا بك هاني كيف هي الاجواء لديك
قناه العربيه لعلى تساقط الثلوج توقفا في
الساعتين الماضيتين ولكن هناك ايضا تغير
في درجات الحراره المئويه التي كانت قبل
تقريبا في او في ساعه الصباح الاولى الصفر
مئويه والان تلامسه الدرجتين مئويه مع
سرعه في الرياح البارده وايضا تجدد السحب
من جديد ودخول ايضا موجه من الضباب التي
تغطي قمه جبل اللوز التي اكتست بالثلوج
وكان هناك تساقط متوسط للثلوج بدا في
ساعات المساء من يومي امس رغم ان هذه
الموجه الاولى للعام او الموجه الاولى
لتساقط الثلوج في العام الجديد ومع توقعات
بدخول لموجه اخرى مساء هذا اليوم طبعا
القمه هذه سلسله الجبال
المتساقطه هل هي كافيه ربما
ممارسه رياضه السكينج
طبعا حجم الكثافه الثلوج لهذه الموجه هي
تعتبر متوسطه هناك في الجهه الاخرى او
ايضا نشاهد بعض المشاريع التي تنفذها نيوم
او مشاريع نيوم وهي من ضمن رؤيه السعوديه
2030 هذه المشاهد الان التي تشاهدونها على
شاشه العربيه هي لمنتجعات سكنيه تستعد لها
يوم بالانتهاء منها وهناك اعمال انشائيه
وتنفيذيه نشاهد اجزاء او اعمال كثيره
انتهت هناك الجهه الاخرى من البحيره وكذلك
منطقه التزلج لم تنتهي ولكن من ضمن الخطه
لن ننسى ان السعوديه تستعد للاستضافه
اولمبياد الاولمبياد الشتويه الاسيويه في
20 29 ولكن هناك من الزوار وكذلك شاهدنا
بعض من السياح الذين قدموا عبر مطار نيوم
بالتجول وكذلك اتعرف على هذه المنطقه خاصه
ان هناك تم تهيئه هذه قمه جبل جوز في بعض
الخدمات سواءا او بعض الخدمات التي تقدمها
الجهات الحكوميه سواء من توفير للطاقه
الكهربائيه او كذلك في بعض الارشادات التي
يزولونها مع تواجد ايضا وحمايه امنيه من
خوفا وايضا منعا لي الانزلاقات التي قد
تحدث على الطبقه الاسفلتيه بسبب متوسط هذه
الثلوج طبعا بدات ثلوج او بدات الثلوج
الان في الذوبان في هذه الجهه ولكن الجهه
الاخرى وهي منطقه روجينا الجديده هناك ما
زالت الكثافه موجوده والتي سوف نوافيكم
بها في ان نشرات القادمه شكرا لك من جبل
اللوز مراسل العربيه هذه الصبيان
صحيفه واشنطن بوست نشرت تقريرا اشارت فيه
الى زياده عمليات البحث على جوجل عن صالات
الالعاب الرياضيه مع بدايه العام الجديد
موضحه اهم الخطوات لتكريس عاده ممارسه
الرياضه
[موسيقى]
وقدم نادي النصر السعودي نجمه الجديد
كريستيانو رونالدو في ملعب مرسول بارك في
حفل حضره 30 الف متفرج وخلال المؤتمر
الصحفي لتقديم الصفقه الاسطوريه قال
رونالدو انه اختار نادي النصر رغم العروض
الاوروبيه التي قدمت له واكد صاروخ مديره
ان الدوري السعودي يتميز بتنافسيه كبيره
معربا عن تطلعه بالمشاركه في المباراه
القادمه اذا قرر المدرب ذلك واضاف النجم
البرتغالي انه يسعى لتحطيم الارقام
القياسيه مع النصر موضحا انه جاء للفوز
وللمشاركه في ثقافه النادي وثقافه
السعوديه
توينجا
[موسيقى]
قصف روسي اوكرانيون متبادل في دونيتك
واعلان الانذار الجوي في خمس مقاطعات
بينها خارقين
في المفاوضات النوويه مع ايران بسبب
خراطها في حرب اوكرانيا
الخارجيه الامريكيه تقول ان الاحتجاجات في
ايران تجاوزت الحدود القوميه والجغرافيه
وزعيم حركه النهضه الاخوانيه في تونس امام
المحكمه اليوم بتهمي تلقي تموينات اجنبيه
شكرا لضيوف المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]